[Musique]
le projet de loi sur le pass vaccinale
entraîne une vague de violence contre
les élus 60 aurait été menacé de mort
depuis le début de l'année selon le
ministère de l'intérieur et député des
yvelines ont également été visés le
masque en extérieur n'est plus
obligatoire dans le département le
tribunal administratif de versailles a
suspendu l'arrêté du préfet des yvelines
une mesure qui portait une atteinte
excessive à la liberté individuelle a
jugé l'instance grève inédite pour
dénoncer le protocole sanitaire dans les
écoles les syndicats d'enseignants
appelaient à débrayer mouvement soutenu
par les chefs d'établissements les
inspecteurs et les parents d'élèves 300
personnes ont manifesté devant la
préfecture à versailles près d'un
enseignant sur deux du premier degré
étaient mobilisés dans l'académie selon
le rectorat de nombreux maires sont
également non content du protocole dans
les écoles 37 édiles des yvelines ont
écrit au premier ministre jean castex
pour demander des changements il
souhaite notamment un allègement de la
charge de travail pour les directeurs et
enseignants et aussi la livraison rapide
autotests et de tests salivaires depuis
lundi votre pass navigo est également un
sésame culturel il vous permet d'obtenir
des réductions dans plus de 300 sites
franciliens 21 lieu dans les yvelines
quatre millions de personnes sont
concernées et puis libinois jean pierre
garcin a conclu son 23e dakar il était
le co pilote de lionel baud / ph racing
le duo termine à la 31e place du
classement des autos dominé par le
qatarien nasser al attiyah
[Musique]
non